DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with
Google Developers
Live here at I/O 2013.
And I am joined right now by a
couple of gentlemen from the
Google Play Games team, I want
to say, if that's accurate.
Lead PM, Greg Hartrell and PM,
Duncan Curtis, thank you both
for joining us here.
GREG HARTRELL: Thanks
for having us, Dan.
Happy to be here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So let's start
by talking about what Hugo
announced today, Hugo Barra,
when he was up on stage,
talking about Google
Play Games service.
What is it exactly?
What does it mean
to developers?
Give me the nuts
and bolts here.
GREG HARTRELL: What we learned
today in the keynote is
there's incredible momentum
around Android in terms of the
sheer number of installs, and
particularly around--
it's shown itself to be this
tremendous gaming platform for
game developers.
And so what we've announced
today is a set of services, a
part of Google Play services,
that allow us to effectively
bring games to the next level
on Android and a number of
cross-platform scenarios.
It's really around
four pivots.
The first is achievements.
So you can have badges that--
virtual trophies--
that increase engagement in your
game, social and public
leaderboards and leverage
G+ circles.
So you could be number one
amongst your friends and maybe
not necessarily number
one in the world.
We have a set of APIs that we
just affectionately refer to
as "Cloud Save" that effectively
squirrel away
state for your game, save game
progress, settings, a number
of other virtual progress
that's in games.
And the last part on Android, we
have Real Time Multiplayer,
which allows up to four player
simultaneous play with support
for more players coming soon.
And the theme around this is
really, we're bringing the
best of Google to gamers now.
The things that we're good at,
which is mobile and cloud, and
allowing game developers to do
what they do very well, which
is make fantastic entertainment
and fantastic
gaming experiences.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Just to be
clear, you mentioned this
cross-platform idea, but
Android, iOS, these are
services that are going to work
across all these devices.
And we saw today in some of
the demos where they were
actually working with
each other.
GREG HARTRELL: Yeah,
that's right.
Part of the services is actually
providing native SDKs
for both Android and iOS.
And then our REST APIs
effectively allow any
developer to integrate across
any interconnected device.
And what's fantastic about
this is just giving game
developers the ability to
build a community around
games, across any number
of screens.
So it's also demonstrative of
our commitment to being a
cross-platform play for
game services as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now I heard
reference to the-- you were
talking about the leaderboard
idea.
Far be it from gamers
to be competitive.
I'm sure we all know that that's
a big appeal to any
gamer to be listed in
the leaderboard.
You mentioned between your
friends, but between the
all-time list as well.
Tell me about the fact that when
somebody beats someone's
score, or you get higher up on
the leaderboard, this gets
posted on Google+?
I could actually brag about
my score, essentially?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Look, of course
you can always brag about it
on Google+.
But what we're really doing is
we're using it as a set of
social discovery mechanisms,
social play mechanisms around
your Google+ circles.
So just how you're going to find
your friends to play with
and who you're going to game
with, and who you're going to
compare yourself against.
You can also compare yourself
against anyone who wants to
put their score out
there publicly.
As I said, you can definitely
still brag on G+.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
good to know.
And then what about the idea
that as you use different
devices, if you achieve or get
to a certain level on one
device, you go to another one
and sometimes you end up
having to play that level again,
which can obviously be
a little frustrating.
As much as you may love
the game, you want to
kind of move on.
But now that will not
be the case, right?
I mean you can actually have
that, move from one device and
pick it up where you left off.
GREG HARTRELL: Absolutely.
And this goes into those
Cloud Save APIs we
were talking about.
Because they're cross-platform,
game
developers now can basically
squirrel away the game save
data, such that that way if you
have won level 14 on your
game on your phone, and then
decide to go home and pick up
a tablet, or if you lost your
device or have a new device,
you can effectively pop open
that game and pick up where
you left off.
And we think that's a really
powerful scenario.
Specifically to that service is
that game developers will
get basically four keys that
they'll be able to squirrel
away 128k of data.
And that's a pretty good simple
surgical tool for game
developers to maintain
that state.
And then because again it's
available on Android, iOS, and
effectively any interconnected
device, we think that game
developers will be able to use
that in really creative ways
to solve this problem that you
just described and probably
quite a few others.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Let's step
back just a little bit.
If you could talk to me about
the game developers community
on Play, where is this going?
What are some exciting
innovations that you've seen
in mobile gaming?
Are there some examples you can
point to that are really
cool these days?
GREG HARTRELL: Yeah.
We've seen a number
of partners.
We have over 30 launch titles
currently that have started
using Google Play Service.
I think Duncan and I have
seen some incredible
implementations of the
game services that
we've launched today.
One of my favorites is a title
called Frozen Front, where
they've taken our Realtime
Multiplayer and they've
effectively created a turn-based
atmosphere.
So this is my definition
of it.
It's a bit of a real time
strategy game, where you move
around pieces on a board.
And then similar to the way a
tabletop game would work, I
would send my moves to you and
then you see my moves play out
on your screen.
So I think that's a really
clever implementation and a
really engaging experience
that comes from that.
DUNCAN CURTIS: I would
say the same.
For me, I really do like Frozen
Front's implementation.
But I really like World
of Goo's leader board.
So as you play through World
of Goo, it's sort of a
building mechanic game.
And as you proceed through the
levels you get more building
materials for your
leader board.
So the way you compare yourself
against the other
people in your circles
is you actually get
to build your tower.
So the more skillful you are
with just a few pieces of
building material you have,
you can actually build a
better tower.
Or you can try again, maybe a
slightly different structure
will actually get you
further along.
And since they actually get
your friends to show up in
that level with you, that your
friends' pictures appear on
little clouds.
For the taller your
building goes.
The little friends' faces are
on clouds so you can see who
you're actually beating.
And it really drove me,
personally, to want to just
those extra few meters or feet
so that I could beat
Greg, in this case.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Not that you
guys are competitive.
GREG HARTRELL: No, no.
Duncan hands down beat
me at that game.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And what about
that multiplayer component?
How much is that becoming a part
of the gaming experience
within what we're talking about
today and going forward?
DUNCAN CURTIS: It's really
becoming an important element.
I mean one of the really key
things that we're launching is
atuomatching.
So you'll be able to not just
play with your current group
of friends on G+ and in your
circles, you'll actually be
able to play with other people
within the world.
So you can jump in and be like,
wow I'd really like to
play a game of "Riptide II." But
I know my friends aren't
around at the moment.
So I'm just going to jump in and
choose an automatch player
and I'll get matched
up with someone
elsewhere around the world.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And how
does that work?
If I'm that other person
somewhere in the world, do I
get a notification that
someone wants to play?
DUNCAN CURTIS: We'll be matching
people up who, at a
very similar moment, have
pressed, hey, I would like to
play a game with another
automatch person.
And it'll be really nice for
players to be able to jump to
those gaming experiences
whenever they want.
Sometimes it's hard to get
your friends to play at
exactly that right moment.
So when it is one of
your friends, we--
let's say I invited you to come
play a game and you're in
my circles.
I said, let's play a game of
"Riptide II." You'd get a
notification.
It would be like, bing, Duncan
Curtis would like to play
"Riptide II" with you.
Click.
Assuming you've got the game
installed, you press Play and
straight into the game.
And our game will begin.
So this is going to be a really
powerful tool for
developers to reengage audiences
with the game that
they may have lapsed
from playing.
Or as a really great discovery
mechanism for me at inviting
friends who haven't played
the game yet.
Because if you haven't had the
game installed when I send you
the notification, you'll be able
to go check it out in the
Play Store.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
Let's go back.
I want to go back to that
cross-platform or cross-device
engagement.
I'm forgetting the name, forgive
me, the name of the
game that was demoed with the
cars racing on the track.
And it was going across
the different screens.
That was fascinating to
see how that works.
DUNCAN CURTIS: I feel
nostalgic about it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
And it was meant to recreate the
idea of the race cars with
the [? trigger car ?].
Anyway, talk me through
what that--
GREG HARTRELL: Yeah,
absolutely.
We have a sample app that's
called Nostalgic Racer that
allows you to have a little
bit of a retro
feel to it that way.
In what's great about that is
just having the ability to use
those services across a variety
of platforms, right?
And so achievements,
leaderboards, and Cloud Saver
APIs that any game developer can
take and, with our samples
or in some of the demonstrations
that you've
seen, integrate those
into the title.
And basically have it work on
an Android device, an iOS
device, or any other
interconnected
device as it were.
And we think that that
cross-platform play creates
demonstrations like those.
And adds a little bit of
a wow factor that way.
But plus what Duncan was saying
earlier is that-- it's
really about developers creating
a really strong
community of gamers that they
have across whatever device
they happen to have access to.
And we know that developers
have told us that that's a
really important
thing for them.
And that's kind of been the
guiding principle for us
designing what we've designed.
DUNCAN CURTIS: I think a good
way to put it is , well would
be to say that, not only will
we enable developers to
actually connect people across
devices where they want to
play, but for the first time you
will really be able to add
your G+ friends on your iOS
device or on your Android
device, or on the web.
And all of those communities
will be able to
feed into each other.
So people will be around
when you want to game.
I think that's really
important.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And tell me,
if you could look into your
crystal ball, where
is this headed?
What are the coming
developments here.
For any developers thinking,
this is awesome stuff today,
but even beyond this is
there anything you can
kind of point to?
GREG HARTRELL: Yeah.
I think today what we focused
on is building this really
strong foundation for
game developers.
And we think of it as kind of
a first step in many things.
And so what we've heard from
our developers is that
integrating with our
game services
have been really fantastic.
One developer specifically
turned to us and said, wow
with multiplayer it would have
taken me weeks if not months
to be able to integrate
something that complex.
And frankly deal with the server
configuration, setting
up peer to peer sessions, all of
the really hard networking
problems that come with that.
And that developer specifically
was able
to do it in a day.
And we were pretty impressed
when we had heard that.
And they were really
obviously relieved
that it was that easy.
So I think that, looking ahead,
what we plan on doing
is listening to our developers
who put together the service
[INAUDIBLE] in their
titles, and launch
it, learn from that.
And a frame of reference here is
to think about Google Play
as really only, it's just
over a year old now.
And the momentum that Google
Play has created is indicative
of the way that Google executes
and the way that we
deliver on a lot of
our services.
We want to maintain that
momentum with games, listen to
our developers, and improve the
services as we go forward.
DUNCAN CURTIS: I can't wait til
we look back in a year and
be like, look how fast
we've come forward.
GREG HARTRELL: Yeah,
absolutely.
DUNCAN CURTIS: And we'll be
developing features based on
our developer feedback and our
community feedback as well.
Those are really important to
us to choose what those next
features and wins for
us are going to be.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
And tell me a little bit about
the experience of working with
these 30 partners.
And how they've been
to work with.
I'm imagining that this has been
an exciting opportunity
for them, but also for us.
GREG HARTRELL: Absolutely.
We have a fantastic roster
of partners.
They come from actually very
different types of studios.
Game developers are very large
outfits or a guy literally in
his basement.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Small, scrappy
developer, yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Are most of
them from a sort of a
traditional game development
background?
Or were some of them almost
starting up in a way looking
at this opportunity?
GREG HARTRELL: The truth is it's
actually been a really
healthy mix.
We've been working with
developers like Glue and
Gameloft who have some
fantastic, really rich
experiences that you really feel
when you play them on a
tablet or some high definition
experience.
But then Duncan brought up
titles like "World of Goo."
And we have titles like "Mega
Jump" that launched today.
I think the other one that we
were playing around the office
was "Plague Inc."
DUNCAN CURTIS: Plague Inc.
was really good.
We've been playing "Virtual
Families" too as well.
We've been playing a
lot of these games.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Be honest,
that's all you guys do all day
long is just to play games.
DUNCAN CURTIS: It's hard.
GREG HARTRELL: I don't
know how we
survive on a normal day.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Somebody
has to do it.
GREG HARTRELL: Right, somebody's
got to do it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Anything else
you guys wanted to mention
while we've got you here?
GREG HARTRELL: I think it really
just comes down to,
we're really excited to see
our partners launch their
games today and create some
of the fantastic gaming
experience they have, hearing
their feedback around what
Game Services has provided
them, giving them
opportunities to engage players,
retain them build
discovery mechanisms for them
to get their games known.
And frankly just having
fantastic experiences that
players are going to
know and love for
many months and years.
DUNCAN CURTIS: This
is just the start.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So if this is
a race-- we're going back to
the car race them-- we've just
gone off the start line?
DUNCAN CURTIS: We've literally
just gone off the start line.
We're excited.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I'm excited to
see what's going to come out
of all this.
GREG HARTRELL: As are we
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Well Greg, Duncan, thank you
both for joining us here.
We really appreciate it.
That's going to do it for
us here at Google
Developers Live for now.
Hang tight because we are going
to be right back to talk
about cloud.
Guys, thanks again for us.
Appreciate it.